and finally Madam Deputy speaker I have
heard I've heard the representations
from The Honorable member for
Stoke-on-Trent North my right honorable
friend for Witham and my right humble
friend from South thanet and the Sun
newspaper about the impact on motorists
of the planned 11 Pence rise in fuel
Duty
I noticed the party opposite called for
a freeze on this Duty
somehow they forgot to tell the British
people they voted against every single
Fury
for 12 years because
because inflation remains High I have
decided now is not the right time to
operate fuel Duty with inflation or
increase the duty so here's what I'm
going to do for a further 12 months I'm
going to maintain the 5p cut and I'm
going to freeze fuel duty to that saves
the average driver a hundred pounds next
year and around 200 pounds since the 5p
cut was introduced
[Applause]
[Music]
Fiona paint all Frozen in today's budget
that doesn't just help families it helps
the economy too because their combined
impact reduces CPI inflation by nearly
three quarters of a percent this year
lowering inflation when it is
particularly High